in this video I want to talk a little
bit about the way translation is
terminated I'm going to mention in
prokaryotes and talk about the
difference in eukaryotes so after we've
had a bunch of elongation steps added a
bunch of amino acids to make a really
long peptide chain eventually
transcription or semi translation will
have to end and how will it end well
there are once it reaches a stop codon
so this here UGA is a stop codon so once
a stop codon is reached
there is no tRNA for stop codons instead
what happens is release factors come in
and they bind in the a site so here we
have a release factor an orange one and
then we have a purple one up here just
to make it colorful and those release
factors will come in one of those
release factors has a gtp on it so when
those release factors come in at this
gtp is hydrolyzed off into a GDP and an
inorganic phosphate and this peptide
chain is hydrolyzed off of the tRNA so
then what happens is that we free up
this peptide chain the peptide chain is
now free the tRNA is free and the
ribosome is free and the ribosome
eventually dissociates that's pretty
much it translation termination costs
the equivalent of one will cost one GTP
which is the equivalent of one ATP
what's the difference in eukaryotes the
the real difference simply is that the
release factors are eukaryotic release
factors otherwise the mechanism is
pretty much the same hope that video was
helpful one last thing i'm atutor if you
live in southern california feel free to
contact me via email and moof university
at gmail.com see the description below
for more details thank you for watching